So far, we looked at
open-end mutual funds
that can kind of grow and shrink
depending on how many investors
want to invest in that fund.
They can grow by
creating new shares
and selling those shares
to the general public.
And they can shrink because
someone who wants their money
back goes to the
fund and says, you
have to buy this back
from me at the end NAV,
at the net asset
value, per share.
But the problem with
it, actually there's
a couple problems, is
that the manager here
has to always keep a little
cash set aside in case some
of the investors come
to him and say, hey,
I want you to buy my share back.
I want liquidity.
And the other thing that
they have to worry about,
at least from the
investor's point of view,
is they can only buy or
sell at the end of the day.
And that will only happen at
the net asset value per share.
And on top of that,
the fund manager,
or whoever's running
the fund, has
to worry about
actually transacting
between all of these
different investors.
Now, on the other
side of things,
we looked at the
closed-end fund.
The closed-end fund
couldn't kind of dynamically
grow and shrink by creating new
shares, or by buying them back.
But what was good about them
is, is that they were freely
trading on exchanges, maybe
on the NASDAQ or the New York
Stock Exchange.
And because there was none of
this kind of back and forth
between the fund
managers, or whoever
was kind of doing the operations
of the fund and the investors,
they didn't have
to put cash aside.
And they didn't have to have
all of this kind of overhead
in dealing with the investors.
Now, you're probably saying,
well isn't there a way?
Or maybe there's a way to
get the best of both worlds?
A fund that could
grow dynamically,
that could create
new shares when
there was demand from investors.
But at the same time,
those new shares
could be traded
on an open market.
And that combination, or
you can kind of view it
as a combination of the
two, actually exists,
and they're called
exchange traded funds,
or ETFs for short.
And you might say, hey, wait.
Isn't a closed-end
fund exchange traded?
And it is.
These actually do trade
hands on the stock exchanges.
But these are officially ETFs.
When someone tells you an ETF,
the way to think about it,
it's a combination of both.
But what it does is it
limits of the interaction.
So when you have just a
regular, open-end mutual fund
any individual investor
can come to the fund
say, here is my share.
Buy it back from me.
Eliminate that share.
And that creates a
lot of overhead here.
On an exchange traded
fund only approved people,
and these are usually
large institutions,
can go to the fund
and say, I want
to buy or redeem a
big block of shares.
So an exchange
traded fund, instead
of creating one
share of time, it
might create 5,000, or 10,000,
or 100,000 shares at a time.
And on the other side
of things, if someone
wanted to redeem
their shares, they
would redeem 5,000,
10,000, or 100,000 shares
at the same time.
And what's good there from
the funds point of view,
is that they don't
have to deal with all
of these small transactions.
They can do big transactions
with big entities.
So that saves them
cost on overhead.
And since these big
people go and kind of
by these big blocks of shares,
they can then go and sell them
in the open market, or
they could trade them
in the open market.
So if want to buy in to an ETF,
instead of buying it directly
from the ETF you
would buy it from one
of these big institutions
that buy big blocks of shares.
So they're now
buying a big block
of-- maybe this is 10,000
shares right over here.
And then they will trade
in the open market.
So you kind of get the
best of both worlds and.
In general, ETFs
also have lower fees.
And they have lower
fees one, because they
don't have to do all
of this back and forth
between each
individual investor.
And most ETFs are
not actively managed.
And when I say actively managed
I'm talking about the situation
where you had Pete.
And Pete says that he's just
an awesome stock picker.
He can beat the market.
He can do all of-- you know he
really researches companies.
And he thinks that
there's some value
that he creates by doing that.
When something is
not actively managed,
and exchange traded funds tend
to not be, they're saying,
look, we're just going
to buy the market.
Or we're just going
to buy some commodity.
So when you go into an
exchange traded fund,
you're really just trying
to buy some asset class,
maybe it's the S&P 500.
Maybe it's some type of
exchange traded funds
that buys gold as assets.
Or maybe it's buying some
other type of commodity.
And so because it's
not actively managed,
the argument would
be, that they don't
need as much in management fees.
So they will have lower fees.
So it's a combination, they
can grow arbitrarily large,
and some of the largest exchange
traded funds are super huge.
They have much lower fees.
And they have this tradability.
You can trade them at any
kind of second on the market.
You don't have to
wait until the end
of the day like
an open-end fund.